alright what's up hot breath averse
welcome to comedians on skype talking
comedy presented by the hot breath
comedy Network if you're watching us on
YouTube welcome just so you know the
only way to participate in these live
Q&A is to actually join our Facebook
group so go in the description and click
that link to get in on more of these q
and A's in the future but for those of
you lucky enough to be a member of this
Facebook group our guest today
started comedy back in 2003 with
comedians like TJ Miller Pete Holmes
Hannibal Buress he's delivered
mattresses he's delivered pizzas he's
delivered for FedEx and now he is
delivering the comedy goods exclusively
to the hot breath Comedy Network welcome
to the show the one and only Nate
bargatze everyone yes yeah used to
selling out like theaters enter arenas
now so it's this is a little bit of a
downgrade I guess for you okay and then
we started the music kept going and I
was like there's no way this musics just
gonna play the whole time it was my
computer oh okay because I was playing
music over here too that's art that's
alright that's our angle in on this
podcast thing is we just play music and
try to distract the guests into
revealing all their secrets yeah this is
gonna be are you in is that is that your
office that you're in with all that like
shiplap in the background your fancy man
I don't know yeah dude
he did all this stuff and then so did we
just
Oh live it you know well congratulations
first off on all your success I mean
I've been a fan for years a lot of
people in the chat have been fan for
years so it's cool to see a comic like
you who just grinded it out just stay
consistent stayed funny stay honing the
craft and now you're like a living
example of what can happen if you just
stick to it you know what I mean yeah I
appreciate it yeah yeah that's what it
is they all just want to they were you
got to wait it out that's all day you
know I felt like comedy you know like
they were comedy wants you to get out
and if you don't stick through it then
you're never gonna see the end you know
so you got to just keep going what it
what does your been your experience I've
opened up all these q and A's would like
just how you personally are dealing with
the current quarantine situation and
maybe tips you have for comics and how
we can maximize our time during this
kind of unknown period hi you sought a
canceled bunch of dates I mean I was
supposed to be like I was playing the
Ryman in Nashville tomorrow this would
have happened
and so I mean I had a very full schedule
I was hoping to tape a special or I
think I'm still trying to tape special
day ended this year but I was like
gearing up for that like I was gonna be
like you know I felt really good and
like with the hour and I was like oh I
bought time I get there I'll be good and
all that so then it all just kind of
came and went and I think what it's made
me realize is you know like I don't have
a podcast or anything like that
and but there's there's times this is
definitely made me think about getting
one just to like have this another
outlet like because you realized that
you know the only thing we have is
performing live or that I have and so
that all got taken and so it's gone and
you know there's other ways to do stuff
to be creative so it's made me think
about that more like maybe think like oh
you know what else do you got a fall
back on you know
but I mean if you're a pure if it's a
newer comic it's like because the
problem is like you just have no way to
go be funny in a way and so doing a lot
of these doing a lot of interviews or
something or like where I'm at least
talking and having to be funny and doing
friends podcast that's a good that's a
good thing to do this time eating you do
one a week just to kind of keep your
chops like you know so that's been a
huge help and then I mean you know and
then a look if you're if you're new or
something it's like I mean it's trying
to start a podcast right start something
think of you know find some way to be
creative you know a new thing I mean I'm
a big like I think you do need to focus
on one thing but this is kind of an
unprecedent president I'm like yeah the
way it is no one's dealt with this and
then so it's like now yeah go do
whatever you know figure out yeah throw
you jokes out write your jokes like you
know I don't know just be ready so when
it's time to come back you're you know
ready to go yeah just stay sharpening
your creativity and whatever way that
means to you seems to be like yeah the
best thing yeah that's yeah that's been
a lot of the advice is like learn new
skills like Jeremiah Watkins was talking
about figure out how to edit your videos
like figure out how to add captions like
do just do things that are gonna
strengthen your brand for when all this
does finally clear up you're actually
gonna be hitting the ground running and
not like oh wait I was supposed to be
working that whole time you know it's
yeah it's a job videos put the captions
in that's a very yeah that's that's
great that's great advice because that's
something you got to do now I mean
you're gonna have Mike there's social
media posting your clips it's got to
have all the captions and all that stuff
and so that's actually very smart I like
it better than my yeah yeah you you have
a social media person don't you like you
outsource that job pretty much I do yeah
yeah so it's it's been huge i've got
there's a lot of comics doing it now and
yeah i've got
I'm all into some of them into doing it
just because I was like it's it's been
one of the bigger things for me is with
social media I mean obviously net
Netflix is the biggest thing but like
I've had people come to shows that only
has seen my Instagram videos they
haven't seen those host specials Wow
they would just be like oh oh you from
this you know they just never watched an
entire special mm-hmm and so it's been a
huge help and you're just constantly
having these videos out I mean I have to
think tick we have the tick tock now
we're putting staying up clips on there
I've actually got everything kind of
deleted off my phone Instagram is about
to be I have it back on but I'm about to
take it back off I want to be out of it
like I definitely don't want to be like
especially during a time like this you
end up looking I was like you look at it
too much I don't like to be influenced
you know I don't talk a lot of politics
or topical things or whatever and social
media is all of that and so like if I'm
just think that it kind of steers your
brain into like coming up with jokes in
that world and I don't like that like I
don't want to be you know social media
can be so negative and so mean and all
this stuff and so I don't want to just
be like up there yelling about whatever
and so like I ended up taking off and
that's why I did have someone run it I
mean I you know I can afford to do that
now versus if you're newer you obviously
can't you know you're not making enough
money to pay for something like that so
you have to you know you're right but
it's to keep you got to be just
consistent we post something every day
yeah I get it like the people that do it
for me they've run through my Clips you
know I've been working with them for a
year or so and they kind of know what to
put and they know how to put his stuff
up that it's something that people asked
a lot is like as they you know some
thought I would be doing it like I've
been unbelievable yeah it's like yeah
you just gotta suck it up and like you
gotta do it part of the job and part of
the yeah you got to be consistent on it
but it's like you know it's like you try
not to get too overwhelmed in
world you know because people get just
caught up I look at like stand-up I
don't know it's like social media like
being funny at social media I just
there's no you're not gonna get anything
out of that I believe like if someone's
great in like oh you should follow this
person on social media it's like I mean
that person probably you know Lister she
become huge or something I mean like
then I can really sell tickets no one's
gonna come see them just you know
because of whatever they're because
they're to want to read and hear other
tweets on stage and so you know I don't
know it just seems like an outlet that's
I I don't know how much time you should
put into it like is creative unless
that's your thing unless you're really
yes some people tour off of it it's just
yeah it depends on who you are but
you're more of like the stage your
that's what I like you like everything
you've built you've like you kind of
alluded to it a second ago where it's
like doing one thing really well instead
of trying to do five things mediocre
just focus on doing one thing really
well and that thing for you was stand up
and I like how you talked about social
media it can become a distraction
especially for us as comedians but one
of my favorite quotes from you is when
you said what you read and think is what
you'll create and I think with comedians
we really do need to be mindful of what
we are consuming because that will
actually translate into what we end up
creating and that can be for the better
or worse yeah I mean like if you need
say you're thinking about your act and
you're like oh I need some more family
stuff it's like well didn't you need to
go hang out with your family more like
you know or I need I want some mall
material then you go walk around the
mall for two days and see if you come up
with stuff and it's like to me that
stuff becomes way more relatable then
being like you know I mean you're also
trying not to write jokes that
everybody's coming up with right like I
don't like coming up with topics that
you know you know I would think about
like this coronavirus thing like so if I
shoot a special kind of after this all
lifts up and we can go back to perform
uh you know I'll probably have a joke
about the krona verse but it's like I
got a do one like that's not going to be
done like everybody else and so you got
to think of say you gotta somehow
find a way to do it that's gonna be
different so many people talk about the
exact same stuff so many people talk
about stuff like I and I had an old joke
I've brought it up before like stuff but
like on The Tonight Show I did a joke
about saying I like Donald Trump this
she's been using in the primaries and
the whole reason for that joke was just
because everybody said they hated him so
that's once that everybody says it's one
more topical things are done and it was
still not topical but it's I just wanted
to try to be like how can I do this that
everybody saying every comedian says
they hate him so how can I say I like
him but without getting killed by you
know everybody because you're saying
something like that and so you got to
figure out those ways you always just
want to figure out a different angle you
know that was an old like Jay Leno thing
they like I remember reading like out of
one of like the comedy Bible or Judi you
know one of those old books yeah but
they were saying like Jay Leno like we
ever had McDonald's joke and then
someone was like what you seen Jay
Leno's McDonald's joke and it was like
because his was the best and everybody
else's was whatever so like unless you
think your joke is the best are
different enough then you know then I
don't know there's no reason to dive
into like a topic that everybody's doing
yeah like you just you just you yeah I
heard you talking about like Dave's
people like Dave Chappelle and Bill burr
are killing it because they have a point
of view on whatever it is they're
talking about like they actually bring
you want another point yeah exactly
that's what you gotta be if you want to
do that stuff and you got to be it's got
to be you got to be at that you know not
me gonna be at that level you're
eventually get at that level but the
point of it is I want to hear what they
think about things and so you're they
that's what they do and they give you
that they you know if you watch Bill
Maher like you're gonna go watch his
show and be like oh I want to know this
guy's opinion on all this stuff or
whoever it could be and so unless you do
if that's your world then yeah dive into
that side of things and if your world's
not that mine tends to not be that more
stories and trying to be relatable and
so you
you do it I mean do it I you know just
talk about your life like and just make
yourself make it very you know personal
in you as a comic and then that helps
when you make it personal it just you
know I don't know you want everybody's
got to be they do want your opinion
everybody's got to be like I want to see
you
like if you're whether you're Chappelle
or whoever if you're whether you're
talking about politics are you just
talking about going to the gas station
everybody's got to want to see you the
comedian go through that experience so
that's what you have to be able to
that's what you're kind of selling to
the audience because you got to be like
here's me going through this you want
the audience to kind of be when they
watch it like I could see this guy doing
this this is what he does like that's
that means they're buying into what
you're what you they they know who you
are and that's when you get to like you
get to another level where then you're
like you've kind of got your that's like
a your voice my kind of thing where you
get your voice and you're kind of like
alright like you know I don't know I get
told a lot like people are like oh you
remind me of my brother or something
like that that's like what I'm trying to
do like I'm not saying I started knowing
that yeah but like you either brother
their friend or you want to be like oh
you're like my husband or your wife's
like mile-wide like whatever whatever
they can do to like relate to you is you
know what you have to be doing yeah and
there's people in the the chat
definitely your your style and delivery
are something that a lot of a lot of
comedians
I mean I've talked to a camera or what
comedian was it maybe like Sam Morril
but it was like a lot of your jokes I
don't know if it's what you're saying if
it's how you're saying it but it's like
the math isn't always there but it like
crushes and like how were you able to
bring in that like as comedians we want
to be more personable on stage and like
actually connect with people like you do
with your audience so what was that
process of like finding your voice I
mean you know you still do it like I do
think I never like that I know I'm just
saying like what everybody always says
but
and the fact that like you never really
find your voice you are always searching
for your voice there's still somewhat
like I think Marc Maron is one of the
best at his voice like what he is on
stage is pretty similar to offstage and
that's where you're I think that's where
your voice is is the fact that like
unless you're doing like you know Larry
the Cable Guy or somebody like if you're
doing some which is great like it's fun
like but this you're doing something
that you're you know personas just your
character or whatever is it's trying to
just be as similar as you are offstage
onstage because once you do that doesn't
know louis c.k said in an interview a
long time ago about he want the older he
got it's like his jokes are easier to
write because everything you say is
funny and everybody like kind of thinks
what you say is funny because you that
means you have your voice that means
everything that you say is like the way
I say it or whether way I do whatever is
like funny so you get it's a slippery
slope because you got to be careful with
it because you don't that's how you can
become bad too because usually people
are people like you know are just like
yeah they're laughing everything and
you're not getting like a true test of
like is this stuff good or not you're
just because they like you like now when
I go onstage we're doing theaters and
people are very excited so when I go out
I can tell that like they're excited to
see me they're excited to be in the room
and but you got to make sure that you're
still bringing it or otherwise you're
like I mean you could really drop off
and it'd become a problem but finding
your voice is like it just takes a long
time I always when I I never I've never
sat down and wrote word-for-word I've
tried that there was an old Patrice and
build I've ever Patrice and Gil I think
a member they told me that like it was
like you didn't want to write it out
word for word you because if you don't
do that it'll kind of change every time
like every time you say it and not not
the bones of the joke the jokes gonna be
working the same way but your hands and
your eyes and your these and like the
little sentences like that
that stuff changes and then that rid
kind of changes and so it kind of feels
it's very conversational and so you're
trying to kind it like our what I try to
do is you're trying to hide the joke a
little bit so you're trying to hide you
don't try to talk the way that I talk
and I always get told I say like a lot
and you know but it's like just how
people talk so I'm talking pretty much
the way that I talk are trying to talk
as close as I can to the way that I
can't and then I always tried never to
be too far away from a laugh whether
it's even the tiniest laugh if it's
anything it's I try to always stay the
farther you get away from a laugh the
bigger that next laugh has to be so I
never want to put that much pressure on
one laugh I mean obviously the biggest
laugh I want to be at the end of the
joke but I never want to put too much
pressure on one flat like one joke or
one sentence I mean you show it needs to
be either very interesting in what
you're saying doesn't always have to be
funny very like people want to hear what
you're saying that oh wow I didn't know
that are it needs to be a big glass you
know or even just a little left but just
you're you know I think I try to
consistently have laughs the entire hour
I've always done it with everything you
just yeah you never want to be too far
away you never want to you know just
farther you get away from laughs to be
like you know like you tell a story
where there's no laugh for two minutes I
mean this story better end with a stain
innovate like yeah
you just put that much pressure on they
can't just do it easy quiet laugh when
you're done with nothing right like that
see I heard it's like okay we're like
the the further between the labs the
bigger the balloon gets so the bigger
the pop better be yes yes so just I
always try to keep it you know just kind
of keep it going all the way through and
you can fill it you can tell when you're
like oh I need something else but
something needs to be there and then so
you had a little funny dumb thing some
of it's just dumb things that you're
adding just to keep them listening and
then you know and then you to get to
your payoff
and can you take us to the moment you're
talking with bill burr and Patrice
O'Neal at the same time is this I guess
you're used to it because you like
developed in New York but like as
comedians we hear these names and we're
like wait what
so they why starts when I moved to New
York so I was in Chicago then I moved to
New York with pea domes I did exactly
crashing I did that with peanuts um I
barked at Boston comedy club with Pete
Pete got me barking and so we stood on
the corner and all that stuff so that's
where Bill and Patrice and them would
come in so Patrice was I think would
have been bright one of the greatest
ever is the he's like you know I would
if you could bring someone back alive I
mean I would bring him back over anybody
over Chris Farley like I just want to
hear what he has to say about everything
but I went to their HBO one-night stand
taping they have with the boat did a
half-hour and I watched that and I used
to I mean I used to sit and Patrice's
Patricia parked his car and I would sit
in it in case
so I'd move it a cop came because he had
parked it you can't there's no the
parking and so I was just sitting in and
driving around the block of a cop came
when they were running their half hours
I would time their sets layout time
Patrice's well he did not ask me I would
just do it like you know like the eager
comedian you're just trying to be
helpful and like I was like hey man that
time I know you only got to do 30
minutes so our time just said you were
like at 33 minutes and I remember he was
like all right and then just gonna walk
away like it was because that he didn't
ask for that and now that I know like in
my head I've never I've never done
anything TV why so I thought you had to
be exactly at that time you know but for
that HBO when I said to you like yeah he
could have done 45 minutes and they
would cut it down to third like it
didn't really matter and you know and so
but I was watching those guys whereas
huge birds my that's my god that's my
biggest you know I mean luckily now I'm
friends with bird and you know I don't
talk to him a ton but but what I've been
very I'm member Goodwin with him on
and that's awesome but he was the guy
that was huge for me like I watched cuz
he was one of the first guys where he
was a kind of hitting his stride in the
clubs
it was Ivan I remember the first first
letterman he ever did I was barking like
handing out flyers on the corner for
Boston on the club and I remember
turning and I was like hey we got a
great comedy show and I gave one to Bill
Byrne I was like ah man I'm so so I was
like embarrass like I was like I'm so
sorry I just didn't I was just kind of
turned like I didn't know and then he
was like hats fine man and he's like and
he was doing his first Letterman and he
was like hey do you know I need to go
run it do you know when he shows and I'm
and of course like I'm a new comic so
I'm like yeah dude there's this show in
this show and I'm like telling him all
the shows that he could go to to run it
but he was like a big deal because I use
the first guy that when I came to New
York you know you're like world is open
up to like you know when you're for
Easter comedy all you know is like
Seinfeld or Cosby or you know whoever
like whoever the famous Chris Rock you
don't know about guys that you don't
know who they are and then when you get
into comedy and you start seeing people
like I saw Bill burr who's nobody at
this point not even he's about to do his
first Letterman and I'm like blown away
like I'm like this is bananas dude I
heard the first same way with Braun
Regan first time I heard Brian Regan CD
I just couldn't wrap my head around
because there's 2003 so he's not famous
you know he's probably selling out
comedy clubs are he is so not comedy
clubs at that point but I remember
hearing it and I just couldn't believe I
was like how is this guy not the most
famous person alive like I didn't
understand you know I was like this is
the funniest human being I've ever heard
in my life how is he not just how is he
not like on Mount rush it's crazy dude
no one's as funny as this guy so your
world gets expanded and you're like oh
everybody there's a lot of really really
good comedians and so then you get a sit
and I just watched Bill burr a lot I
watched burr
I mean obsessively I've you know I would
watch them at outfit clubs I'd watch him
I remember going to Caroline's and he's
not even had their the rooms not even
sold out at Caroline's I remember is
Opie nante the famous Philadelphia
incident I remember when it happened he
came back and was telling us about it
before it kind of blew up on YouTube
we're guys the show was crazy like I
mean he was you know I've not that I've
really ever told him any of this stuff
because obviously I wouldn't it be very
weird and awkward yes we've said we've
sent alone to I mean I've asked him
questions like I've talked to him about
like those days cuz I did kind of tell
him like how like seeing him and Patrice
and asking about just cuz I was younger
comic watching all that and asking him
about that stuff but it was but yeah I
mean he was everything man he was he's a
it's it's one of the biggest deals for
me was and that I still do watch him is
just to watch his path you need to see
comics paths mm-hmm so you know find a
comic that like you know how is what say
you got to have a comic above you and
below you you need to have like someone
that you talk to that's right above you
and then you need to talk and you need
to help someone that's right below you
in comedy because you need to you know
there's no point in going if you're
starting today you don't need to go talk
to Ray Romano about stand-up you're you
have nothing to relate he hasn't done
open mics in 30 years
like there's nothing he can really tell
you you know besides like the basic
information that you would get is they
just work hard write jokes all that
stuff you need to talk to some of it's
like two years in because that person
would know more than anybody that's
that's the what you need to learn is
what to do in two years versus what to
do in 20 years and then you always think
you'd have someone below you so you can
resave this stuff to someone because you
need to constantly be hearing yourself
say it so you need to be saying it and
helping someone else you know below you
can kind of talk and that way you're
always just talking about comedy you
know
yeah always be a boom great advice
so let's uh let's get into these other
these questions in the comments I could
sit here and interview all day but I
know people are also wanting to jump in
here with their questions as we do here
so the the first one I think it's only
right this is a comedian from Chicago
actually where you started so his name's
MIT wolf and his question is I'm in year
three still open miking if you could do
your first three years all over again
would you do anything differently if so
what I you know I'm not a I would always
I never do a do anything different I
always say you got to do you got to
learn everything through experience so
there's not like something that you
could be like we'll go do this like
you're not gonna be good enough to go do
this well you realize like when you're
first starting when in three years you
know so I was in I mean if you're he's a
Chicago Chicago was much different than
I was when I started I think now they've
got much more of a scene and people can
be there and you can actually be seen in
Chicago like they come and you know if
you want to do anything you can do it
anywhere now so I try and think three
years I mean I moved to I was in Chicago
then I moved to New York and then I
started barking but I wouldn't do any of
those things different I never have like
great I never have great like you know
trying to think like any like old stuff
like I wish I knew this or an omission
either cuz I mean you got to go through
all this stuff if you're not out there
that's the only thing you have to be
doing it every night boom you have to
like I'm a big look if you have a
girlfriend a wife husband whatever if
they are in your way and you try to like
be like yeah well I gotta do stuff with
my girl like I can't let go do all this
stuff then you just won't make it
probably like because you're you know I
say this a bunch and a lot of things but
no one cares that you're trying to be a
comedian no one needs you to be a
comedian no one needs me to be a
comedian no needs bill burr to be a
comedian we're all choosing a job that's
like winning a lottery ticket you're
choosing a career where you can make
zero dollars or you can make 950 million
dollars like Seinfeld like that's your
window your window it can be all over
the visor you make a million you can
make know whatever so if you don't
obsess over
then you will never do it because if
you're not obsessing over it someone
else is obsessing over and they spot the
fact that they will just be around you
just gotta be around you've got to be
even if you're not doing stand-up every
night like you just have to be where
everybody knows your standup everybody
knows you're doing stuff and you got to
be soaking everything in that I don't
know that ever to this question but yeah
three years in like just keep doing you
know you got to keep doing what you're
doing you know I mean you can obviously
probably maybe think about moving to New
York or LA I live in Nashville now I
moved a little bit Ellis I was in
Chicago New York for nine years LA for
two so I think it is good to be but
Chicago is at least if you didn't want
to move to New York LA Chicago's you
know the best
besides that yeah and this also can tie
into a big question just the show gets
in general is about taking the leap to
go full-time now you seem to take like
and this is how I became full-time was
more of a gradual route where you would
actually work
you would bark and do shows late at
night and then stay up for your job at
FedEx at 5:00 a.m. and you just stay up
all night and then go straight into work
but what was that process of going
full-time and then this can also tie
into Earl Anderson and also he asked any
advice on self-doubt so like what was
your transition to go in full-time and
how did you deal with the self-doubt
along the way I was a little bit lucky
in the fact that like I got married in
2006 so then my wife when she moved to
New York she got a job she had a job
that was good and I was I was probably
making twenty grand in comedy in like
2006 so I was able to kind of like I did
a couple like temp jobs but then around
2006 seven I was able to kind of like
basically just be doing comedy and I was
making like 20 like it like I said like
20 grand and so I remember I just wanted
to get to make whatever job I would have
like I didn't go to college so I wasn't
ever going to have some big high paying
job so I was like if I
wait tables if I can make what I would
be making waiting tables in comedy
that's all I needed
so if I could make $30,000 as whatever I
was like then I'll be fine and now
that's you know that's what I'd be doing
anyway I have no education like I'm not
gonna have some big big paying job so
like I would just always tried it like
just you have those little goals you
never want to get too big on your goals
because they're going to be pretty tough
to reach if you're five years in and
you're like my goal is to make a million
dollars well you could be you could be
one year way you could be twenty years
away from that so you always want to
have goals that are that that can be
reached your goal shouldn't be too high
you know when I was watching Bill burr
and when I was starting out my goal was
just to get off that corner I didn't
want to hand out those Flyers I didn't
want to stand out in 20-degree weather
and hand out flyers so that was my only
goal and so I did whatever I had to do
to get off that corner and then I can go
and then go to the next step and then my
next goal was to like I don't know like
say I wanted no one to ask me to part
because I used to always get you know
you can do my show but I need you to
hand out flyers and so I was like I
wanted to get to the point where they
would be embarrassed to ask me to hand
out flyers epical we can't ask Nate so
then you just you're then I was just
trying to get to that goal so when you
have those you could be much more
aggressive towards those goals
because they're not as high as they
should be your goals will constantly
change they're always going to change
whatever your dreams are they can change
I want to do a sitcom
I've tried eight times and I've been
told no eight times and it is what it is
man like it's been the hardest thing to
do but you know whatever man it's taken
forever and I mean I'm in the circles
doing it we shot a pilot we did
everything it didn't work out so you got
to just keep doing it like you wouldn't
get told no you know Mike Vecchio no
you're about to interview with my best
friends one of the I say this one of his
quotes all the time which maybe he's
gonna say it just like he's like he
would always say you got to get the nose
out of the way and I always loved it
like
you got to get you got to get told no
out of the way so you're gonna get if
you try to like get on a show that you
know they're not going to have you well
you need to go ahead and get told no
buggin so go like you know it's not
don't do it too or don't be ridiculous
like you know if you're like I've done
four shows and I'm trying to go do you
know the comedian just you know show
whatever the show in Chicago if it's
still there but that was the best show
just to be unbelievable but if you are
like an open mic are trying to get on
that show it's like that's ridiculous
but if you're like I feel like I'm ready
it's like yeah then maybe go ask them
and then you're gonna get told no and
get your nose out of the way you got to
get your nose out of the way great all
right well this is um this could be a no
Paul Schneider says is Nate looking for
a socially distant BFF if so I'm willing
to step up so he's gonna be in like you
know the first notes out of the way
we're going to do one more no and then
we'll be yes also let's just you know
getting it started changing lives here
Nate alright the next comes from skip on
gel he's out in Louisiana he says do you
have a particular writing exercise or
discipline you use often I so I've never
written word for word I've never I've
tried it I've written in a notebook I
remember sitting down and making myself
to it I honestly don't I'm scared
every day that I don't know if I'll ever
come up with another joke mm-hmm I've
lived in constant fear of that I have no
system to make myself come up with these
jokes there's a lot of trust in myself
that I think it's going to happen I I
mean you know when I did my sermon I did
full-time magic on Comedy Central I I
mean I was like I'll never write jokes
that good ever again like I'm done and
then I did the stand-ups and I was happy
that and then that sort of staying up
she's like oh I don't know whatever I'll
do again then you have to see if you
always you never feel you should you
should never feel like you're you write
a great joke and you're like I don't
know how I'll ever top that joke you're
in constant fear and panic that you're
never going to come up with anything I'm
scared I have a new hour and I'm just
gay
after that hour as I do I can catch
myself on stage as I'm doing this new
hour and I'll be thinking how can I ever
come up with more material like I'm I
think that as I'm telling these new
jokes because I'm just so I'm like I
came up with these it's gonna go away at
some point you know like you're like I
don't I always thought like I wish I
made myself right in the fact that I
wish I had this system in place that I
could do it now all that being said I
don't have any missus in place maybe it
doesn't work for you comics or you know
for how hard we work we're also some of
the laziest people alive and so but I
know that I Pete I keep note a notepad
in my you know my phone and I type these
notes down it's a what I do come up with
a new joke I do think of it a lot and I
just you know I can make myself my brain
kind of get into searching mode like
there'd be times I'll be like you know
at with my new hour I wanted I wanted
like maybe one or two more wife jokes
mm-hmm like I wanted a couple more wife
things so I was just a little more
conscious I just kind of opened myself
up to like going like alright I need
some wife stuff and you just kind of
tell your brain that and you kind of
just I don't know then it makes you more
aware sometimes I'm like I don't want
any more family stuff I want something
that's like not family and so then I'll
just you know you got to go do stuff
that was a big bill burr thing go have
experiences go do something crazy like
you know I'm writing a joke about
chuck-e-cheese and I came up with this
or this thing that was chunky cheese and
I've actually gone with my daughter a
few times just trying to get material
she has fun and then I get to kind of
have the experience I can cuz I want a
couple other things so it's it's go had
these experiences you know I know
Seinfeld writes he you know has his
makes himself write every day
maybe it's like go around look on the
Internet I've downloaded little apps I
had this curiosity app that just puts
like weird facts out and sometimes I'll
go through those sometimes it's just
like getting your brain like kind of
thinking in a different thing yeah but
that's where you don't go to
don't get on social media too much
because then you end up you don't want
everything to be negative unless that's
your thing unless you're you know not
sure a comic that wants to be like that
but you can be very influenced with that
stuff and then you end up riding a joke
that's like very like let me to you know
yeah all this stuff like yelling at
everybody great advice
so yeah that's something I really
appreciate about you is that you draw
from things outside of comedy as well
like your inspiration to move to New
York was sparked by hearing a quote that
wasn't even really related to comedy
yeah well that wasn't that was my move
to LA I was the New York LA okay yeah
the New York spark was the movie
comedian okay I was in Chicago yeah you
saw that right yeah
and watch that watched it a million
times uh-huh and I've got to know orny
Adams
he's a great dude comes off in that I
know he just very very funny too Airy
like he's a comic that's like a killer
man like it would be I would always hear
stories together you know Bob Marley
yeah I heard he's like he runs the
Northeast yes yeah it's so like I met
Bob Marley but I remember like Bobby
Kelly would always like talk about like
Bob Marley would murder like like I love
that's something that newer comics need
to have you know that I think this is
there because there's a mix of comedy
that I think there's a lot of comics now
that like laughter is not the most
important things of it and it's about
like being one or whatever it whatever
it is right so if you look at I came up
in the New York Times and like where
guys would murder dude like Ben Bailey
Greer Barnes
I mean murder like nope I can't believe
they're watching this messed up that
needs to happen yes if daddy come back
it's like there's a new way of people
writing I think comics writing jokes
were they're very safe they're like it's
like well like none other stuff is very
funny so if you don't laugh is like it's
kind of fine none of its that's funny
it's all like oh yeah that's a good
point like all that kind of stuff right
and
so we yeah if you making writing
material that's a whole this is I'm
going on a teeny the whole crowd work
idea to is it I mean it fury eighths me
like a new hour of material that's the
hardest thing you can do I'm not saying
don't do crowd work I'm not saying I
like crowd work most a lot of friends do
crowd work I've done crowd work I get it
I'm not saying I'm against it but I
think if you want to go to an the
highest level of a stand-up comedian you
have to have material you have to write
material crowd work is you know there's
only so many divorced people and the you
know what are you divorced in the crab
would interracial couple what do you
like there's only so many different
types of people in the crowd so like you
crowd work you can can become become
very stock jokes it can become you know
you're just doing the same jokes to a
different audience but they don't know
but they feel like it's very personal
and so again I'm not anything against
crab burger not saying it's a it's not a
bad thing to learn and be able to do but
the hardest thing you can do as a comic
is right and an hour of material you're
writing a joke that people don't know
you and they laugh at that's and you're
not at someone like you're not like
going like what is this look at this
guy's shirt like that's your you're
creating something in your dumb brain is
my dumb brain yeah that well that I've
never met lack and they that's unreal
and that's that's the hardest thing to
do and so that's something that I think
comics
I hope this younger generation that
comes up it's like get back to like
murder library like three stage in like
you know I always just say like get up
five minutes that that you know destroys
I get you know you got to get a five
minutes that that think about like if
Jimmy Fallon walked in and says you
wanna do the Tonight Show I need to see
your best five minutes you should know
exactly what that five minutes is that
you would do don't be like well I got a
bunch of stuff know what that is and
that it's jokes that you need to have
worked out and work through and like
Donnell multiple times
I know it's hard when you're first
starting you do an open mic since kind
of the same comics in the crowds it's
like try to figure a way to get in
audience are you know and if you do much
of mics if you don't feel there's a lot
of people doing it but you should all be
trying to work on jokes and learn how to
make it great
that's a huge huge thing sorry I don't
know what this is even a better no that
was right no that was
I love it's like you got a murder it's
like how New York comics talk about you
just got a murder dude like Robert
Kelley would say you got a kale dad you
got a kale
it's yet it's the hardest thing to do
and I not try to do the hardest thing to
do I think people get sick I remember a
comic a long time ago starting and he
got offstage and it was like whatever
like it's it was bad
I like I almost walked up to and I was
like you know we were just doing some
dumb bar show and so I was about to I
was about to say to him I was like
oddest crowd stinks dude like I bombed
too and before I could say it he was
like it's pretty good and I realized I
was like oh that guys never heard
himself murdered so like he thinks that
was good and it was awful in a Jeep if
you don't get laughed Rangers to be like
thinking I'm doing good and you're not
getting all right because that's that's
what happens everywhere you go so if you
don't know what a hard laugh of a from a
crowd sounds like you never know what to
get to and if you don't and so if you
don't have it and I remember that was a
big moment for me just to hear him like
be like wow that was good and I was like
like you got zero let it was
uncomfortable yeah me in the room he is
used to being uncomfortable so he
thought it was fun so before we get a
next question what was what was the
quote you heard that inspired you to
mount la what winch Rob he was like I
think he was like Elvis's he worked on
Elvis like he was a dude that did
Ocean's eleven and any big producer died
not long ago so I read his book and it
was just about him starting and then his
career he's got a crazy grits a great
book and so he said
when he was like he was in the maybe an
agent at WME in New York or something
and he said in the book he said he knew
any time he started feeling
uncomfortable it was time to make a
change and so then he moved to LA I mean
I read that quote two months after I
read that quote I moved to Los Angeles
from New York because I knew they made
so much sense to me and it's the best
quote I've ever heard is the fact that
like if you start building cars like the
guy that was living in Chicago yeah
if you're live and you're having no
trouble getting on any show in Chicago
you can get up as much as you want and
you're kind of looked at is like one of
the older comics or a higher level comic
then you have to move and you need to
shake it up if you don't you will get
stuck are you or just get stuck there
and you're just going to be the older
guy and new comics are gonna come and
they're gonna pass you and they're gonna
move and then you're gonna end up you
can start becoming bitter and you could
start a minutes gone ends over you're
never like I felt like that when I was
in New York a lot of comics with my
friend stay in New York but I knew when
I was in New York I got past my goal is
to get past at all the comedy clubs so
once I got past at all the comedy clubs
I knew like alright I need to change it
up I need to go put myself with I was
getting up everywhere I wanted to get up
I did a half-hour comedy special I did
late night shows I did all this stuff
but I knew that I needed to change it up
because I was getting too comfortable
and I'm budell any when I first moved to
LA I was like you know I had a half-hour
on Comedy Central
you know I like did a bunch I had like
four Conan's I had all this stuff and
then one night I remember I supposed to
open supposed to do a show with bird and
bird like ended up rescheduling and I
went and did an open mic on like a
Friday and I mean I felt like panic
because I mean I have you know I have
more TV critic than most of these people
but nobody cared that I had these TV
credits not like I walked into LA and I
was like I'm here let me onstage as much
as I want so I I had like I mean I
panicked in the fact that like oh I
gotta get it to get like and so then you
just start going like I gotta go start
going back out every night and I was
just hanging out at shows man like I was
getting up on all these shows and I had
more credit like you just can't you know
all these things would be allowed to
like walk in but I wasn't so I just had
to go hang out and get back to the grind
that I was in and I wasn't feeling that
in New York that panic anymore I start
filling that panic and then you start
like and then I moved to New York and
then I started like dude I would do like
my greatest hits in New York I would
just you know murderer
like I would say murder
like I remember Louis Katz close friends
like he was in moved in New York and I
remember he first came and he like he
would always be trying these new jokes
as like Louie I go nobody's seen you
like the same way no one's seen me in LA
I said you got a murder dude like when
you move to a new city
go do your best of your best jokes like
make a point so when you get on these
shows you destroyed because then
everybody starts going like like it's
like it's another level because oh and
then people are like whoa and then you
start getting on other shows and then
all this falls into place and then
you've moved up a lot quicker in this
new city and if you went and like was
like I'm just gonna do my new jokes so
every night like no one's going to care
like you're gonna you may get in the mix
yo murdered you do an open mic and
you're in a new town that's the greatest
thing in the world when you go on the
road and go to some towns open mic right
and you would gonna do your we're just
slaughter like yeah you're just like the
like that's the best that's what you
hear think of that feeling yeah I'm I
live in New York this is what we did you
know five years old yeah you just go
this new place Mert it's great yeah so
and that's what's great and this ties
into the next question and we're gonna
try to start firing through these
questions here this is Lee Hudson says a
that's what's great you murder but with
your energy it's like you're not like
Godfrey like just built like blowing up
the room with energy you're like you and
it's still murders and Lee asks do you
think it took
people a while to get your low-energy
style I had to because I followed
Godfrey who was following Godfrey
sylvans
and like all them in New York I learned
that I had to like I can't match their
energy if I remember one time to show
Rory Scovel and I remember I try to
match Rory skulls you know he's a weird
and loud and yelled all this stuff
so Roy is very easy to like fought like
be like I want to do that because it
seems very fun and I tried it one night
after him and I bomb did Jay Larson was
there he's like yeah why are you trying
to match his energy and I was like
you're right I shouldn't I should just
done me so you got to do what you do and
so what I learned to do a quick easy way
to get people into your rhythm is you
get your first joke or two is gonna not
work but that's how you get them into
like so I learned that I needed them to
hear my voice so I would always start
very weird and awkward I would always go
on stage and I still do it now I go on
stage on my alright here we go
I hope this goes good maybe this is not
going to go good I don't know like I
don't really care you're gonna get
laughs just for but those are not
important laughs I'm just trying not to
make my first joke not get a laugh so
I'm singing a bunch of dumb stuff to
make them hear my voice get into my
rhythm and then they go okay and then
the audience is like alright I know what
this guy does and then you get into your
first joke and now I've got them into
the way I talk like I have always had to
learn how to get them into my tone so
just go on stage and whatever you do
just say Gump's you know blegh alright
here we go this is I hope this goes good
whatever you're you know right persona
if you're you know like a cocky persona
you could be like this is gonna be the
best part you bet you could yell that
it's just kind of throw away stuff so
the audience can then hear your voice so
it's not just a shock you know gotcha
and this this can also Trent Babb has a
says your jokes seem conversational
which I guess that ties into your rhythm
your song is your conversation style so
with it being more conversational do you
have a writing partner that you talk
things out with no I'll try sometimes
just for my friends I mean I don't have
someone specifically
but I'll call comics and be like you
know my the guy that opens with me like
Brian Bates like meeting him talk a lot
of bags this funny and then I'll say it
I kind of know before the joke ever it's
the stage if it's funny or not I've like
thought about it enough and that the
older you get the longer you do comedy
you can tell when you're like I've never
been a guy that I don't throw every joke
onstage I would see a lot of guys do
that when people would always be like
you know I remember going the road we
would do like a show and then we'd go do
some other like local show and they're
like I'll just do this new stuff I've
never tried and I never understood that
because I was like I just did all my new
stuff on the state like I never had just
like 20 minutes of jokes sitting on the
sidelines everything that I think of is
out there maybe there's new ideas I
haven't put into play yet but it's not
many I mean I don't have like a surplus
of just you know and I have a book of
just 50 ideas right that I've never
tried everything that I tried everything
that I come up with it's either I'm
trying to put it in my act at that
moment or it's gone or like I won't do
it again maybe I think of it again later
on but like it's I don't just sit and
have this stuff like sitting on the
sidelines everything I put everything
goes up there and they keep stuff
conversational a great way to do it is
to either like when you do radio
interviews and you got to be funny
during radio interviews like where they
tell you you got to do your act like be
funny like that's it you know you try
not to do your act straight up and then
also just tell it see if you can put it
in a conversation with some friends and
stuff great way for it to learn to be
conversational so you don't just sound
like you're just doing your stand-up
like you know at a party you just kind
of like crowded like you know it's
basically you're telling someone hey is
this funny and then you kind of tell
them and then see what their reaction is
yeah I've heard you even say you'll kind
of talk through jokes like while you're
doing dishes and stuff just in passive
time you'll also kind of be working out
I think about it all the time yes if I
have any joke I'm constantly it's
running through my head and I'm and I
and so when I take it to the stage it's
it's almost already been done in my head
a hundred times so it's not like I'm
like I'm not
totally reliant on the audience and I'll
put it in like the middle I actually I
open with a lot of you stuff like I'm a
big like with a have an hour you know
now doing an hour I open with usually
new stuff because I'm just so excited
about it that's something you got when
you you start doing when you start
headlining and do an hour you someone's
gotta move stuff around because you get
your get tired of some stuff and so then
you need to put new stuff in front of
that or you got to leave a new thing
towards the end just so you're excited
to get to that end yeah so you're not
cuz your energy will change once you get
past the new stuff then you're just kind
of like going through the motion alright
this is judge Jason P Leonard he says I
booked you he books that he's Lafayette
Comedy in Louisiana he books all that
great shows he says I booked you in 2015
weekend of your brother's wedding you
were a week off first Tonight Show
appearance you were great and talked
shop to all the local comics it's been a
pleasure to watch you blow up if there
was one joke you could steal from any
comedian and make it your own what would
it be I mean there's gonna be plenty
Kylie I don't know I don't know if I can
think of one on the spot I was trying to
like I don't know I can't think of it I
can't think of one on the spot it's okay
I always loved you know the Louie CK
joke when he said he's with his family
on vacation and when he goes to vacation
his family the only is his only vacation
is when he shuts his wife door and walks
around the van to his side of the door
that just like so that would be one that
I would I get that would that would fit
very much into my act so like that's why
I would want that joke cuz like that's
something that you know sometimes you
can there's a lot of jokes that you love
do you like I can never say those jokes
that one I could say and that one I
would love to have so that would be this
one there's no face with it but it says
was it your idea to do the track titles
on your first two albums it added
another dimension of humor to them yes
so when we first were there tell me how
to do
track titles and had to go through and
come come come with them up again
the most common way everybody does is
just name you know Walmart wife like
whatever the thing is
and so I I was like what if I come up
with some different way Kyle Kinane came
up with a unique way I forget what I
think he did like CD names of our tracks
of like an album of music album
you know Dana Tosh did one two three
four he didn't umbers so a way that I
came up with it mine is like the first
one yelled at by clown was like thoughts
in my head during the show and then I've
done like a conversation with my
daughter and then maybe I did another
one the other way I did it so now I've
just started doing it that way so yes
here's my way to come up with it it's
actually backfired on me in the fact
that like I had to do some old jokes cuz
I was doing like a corporate gig I'll
pull out like The Greatest Hits cool
again like I'm going back to that like
trying to murder okay so I'm just
yanking the my top greatest hits I've
ever done so I'll go back and listen to
an old album and because I didn't name
them correctly I couldn't find some
jokes and he was infuriating I was like
sit there I'm trying to find like this
thing to listen to this old joke so I
could remember it and I'm like what a
stupid way to name these titles I just
had no idea alright
and I let's do the final one here maybe
before some closing advice for comics
this is from max price and thank you to
everyone that posted your questions and
I'm sorry we didn't get to all of them
but I think we still got we still got a
lot of good information out but this
one's from max Price who asked did you
hold on to material for more than a year
before your first album or have you
always written usable material as
quickly as you do now now I held on to
just now I'm starting now with once the
stand-ups came out that was when I
started had to throw stuff away
do not throw stuff away don't think you
record an album you have to be donut my
yelled at by a clown AB
I have a lot of my stuff on my Comedy
Central special and on the present
because just I like not to be me
but when you first put your first album
out nobody cares
no one's gonna listen to it it's I mean
nobody you will never run into a problem
of people being like it's just from his
out but like maybe you have a couple
people commented that are like real fans
and they've been there for a long time
but when you're first start and you do
your first album like if you get a
special you need to put everything that
you did on the album on that special
bill bird stuff is I think the same
everybody I talked to Tommy John again
about it one day like and he was like
yeah you put the best stuff out we think
like we're supposed to be like louis c.k
doing an hour every year when you're
five years in and nobody knows your
stuff like so when you get your first
chance put it all out there like to do
your greatest weight like so if you're
if you even if you've done two albums
you know and then HBO comes because I
wanna do an hour special yeah then go
grab your two stuff from that albums
like now if you have it there's
circumstances obviously if you have a
big fan base from your albums or
whatever then maybe you do need to
change it up but like in general you
when you're when you get a big
opportunity take advantage of it and
then and go murder so yeah murder
it's like murder firt it seems it hurt
so you got to put the gravel in it
murder
take notes comics murder first and all
else be funny first that's that's what a
big theme and doing over 200 interviews
with comics has been with like the most
successful ones is like just get funny
first don't try to worry about what's
the shortcut what's how do I get around
the work it's like just be funny and
that'll create a lot of the
opportunities you get yeah you're gonna
be trying to find look I try to find all
the shortcuts I mean I try to do it I'm
not selling you not to go try to find
them go try to find and so then you can
learn that they're not there on your own
but you learn it on your own you know
and always prove yourself interest maybe
get a blow-up look
sort of disease and sorry I'm not like
frigid and but like I was like around
his world I mean that dude was doing
open mics with us and then was hosting
the MTV Movie Awards like it was it was
insane like seeing his like he just blew
up immediately like so sometimes people
get lucky they grow and they blow up you
know Pete Davidson was when he started
he was I'm older than him obviously but
he was like a kid yeah and then you know
and then he's like 20s on us known as a
celebrity like so people have different
past you know either making it 20 or 40
I feel like that's the way it goes
no no one makes it at 30 it's either 20
or 40 but how old are you
41 41 okay well then there's there's
living testament right so haven't made
it oh please you're selling out multiple
shows at theaters man like you're
killing it and you're an inspiration to
all of us comics we really appreciate
you doing this do you I appreciate do
you uh do you have any closing advice or
any like of your favorite comedy wisdom
that you've gathered over being around
the top comics in the world
some of it like so be obsessed is my
advice to a lot of people be obsessed
with it okay work as hard as you can get
up as much as you can you know it's not
like you have to go sit there and write
all day long but just go be out be
amongst comics hang out with comics be
around have a fun time drink party you
know it's like we're in the field that
you get a drink every night like at work
that's truly work like it's it's hanging
out and then you know so be obsessed
that comfortable thing if you start
feeling comfortable that's the best
advice you can ever take if you're it
wasn't my if you start feeling
comfortable it's time to make a change
if you're in your combi scene and your
that you can feel yourself be the higher
up of the scene it's time to make a
change maybe you know whatever whatever
you can do you know and the other advice
for this is probably more on older
comics I remember and always told me be
comfortable with silence and so I think
this is more it was like when I was
first starting out it's not it's not
really advice that you know you don't
need to really worry about silence you
need to try to be hearing laughs you're
only doing five to ten minutes but when
you when you start
headlining for the first time it was a I
learned like it's like be comfortable
sense be comforted with like some pauses
and like you know sometimes it's good
hearing a big room of 2,000 people you
could hear a pin drop is just as good as
hearing laughter like you know because
you got their attention
yes and so even though it should it be a
long thing like I said you want to be
very close to laughs but even if it's
like 20 seconds and stuff like you know
when you hear that complete silence that
means man these people are engaged and
they're really listening to what you're
saying and that's a and that's a great
great thing how do you create that
engagement I mean you just got a you
feel like you're always on top of them I
feel like I never tried to you know like
I don't ever leave too much like that's
never been too far away from laughs yeah
they kind of you know you just all you
there's in a way there's a panic up
there and the fact that you're I always
know where I'm going I always know where
you're going always know where you're
going to begin always know where you're
gonna want to end if you start a new
joke at least have the way to get into
it and a way to get out of it you don't
want to just start a joke where you
don't know how to get out of it and you
should have different exits like you
know I have very lives longer jokes
where I can like I can tag it five times
and I can only tag it one time and you
know and you can fill it out maybe if
it's a good crowd I'm gonna tag it all
five if the crowds not you know if it
feels like they're not getting it like
other crowds I'm only going to tag it
once you just get out of the job right I
was like you just kind of filled the
room out it's all a timing is a very you
know timings big it's all a very like
fluid kind of thing man like different
crowds can make you do different things
you know you have quick lappers you have
long laughters you have people that clap
a lot yeah you know people that you feel
like you gotta stay on top of and you
feel like you're flying because you're
like I'm about to lose these people you
know when you're doing a Late Show slip
or you can film know the films start
like looking around like they're like
all right like you know ya know just say
what I mean you're like you gotta like
stay humble and stuff like that did all
chase yeah there's a difference between
like engage silence like you said in
the apathetic silence it's a fine line
but you said you can feel them being
engaged is it that personal material
that makes them engage through the
silence is that something one thing I
learned with personal material is I
remember I added an old joke about
something about me a guy met made a mess
turd messaged me on Facebook and I was
like message to this guy and I even know
this guy was and like it was it wasn't
even that great of a joke but when I
always noticed it wouldn't get the
biggest laughs but that was the joke
people would always come and bring up to
me after the show and I was like why are
they pointing out this that's the worst
joke of those sets the other stuff
murders it was because that's personal
so they come up to me because they're
like I've done that dude and so like
then that joke means more to them than
the other jokes that don't mean anything
to them like that are just funny like
you can be very forgettable too like you
know you can watch a guy go onstage and
murder like we've been saying and then
no wonder and you go you when people
walk out of a room you'd be like hey
what what jokes did he do you'd be like
I don't know is easy cuz none of them
were personal they were all just jokes
like that anybody could kind of tell and
not to say that they're not funny and
that's not a good thing to do but if you
make them personal and people are gonna
come up to you after the show and be
like dude I done that I did yeah all
right I've done that I've been through
that exact thing I always think that you
want to be either be you just be the
dumb guy and they can either laugh with
you or laugh at you so there's either
gonna laugh with you because they relate
to you or they're laughing at you
because you're an idiot
but both laughs count doesn't really
matter how you laugh so you know that's
how I always kind of do perfect all
right well thank you so much we actually
went into overtime here so I appreciate
you sharing your time I was sure to text
the mic and let him know that you said
screw him and we'll go over if we need
to look one of the best joke writers
ever Greta Mallika David yeah I started
with BEC you mean him were the exact
same times honestly one of my best
friends is the best and you know I mean
no one writes like he does he's someone
you need to ask about writing yes that
guy does it the correct way you know
I'm more natural Becky owns uh what's an
old I try to think he's I get hit at
work really hard like Larry Bird he's
like a guy but he's had like shoot
left-handed for a whole year which I'm
just joking I'm not that I'm not that
confident so but Becky owns the best so
enjoy yeah he's gonna be great so Nate
thank you so much for doing this man
we're we're gonna let you get on no you
have more press to do today so is there
anywhere you want us to go support you
or check you out or anything you want to
promote uh yeah I mean just this you
know just the social media all that
stuff do it you know all that stuff
Netflix special al that's been out you
know so whatever neighbor gets you all
of its neighbor gets you just Google all
that stuff and so yeah that's it perfect
all right well Nate bargatze thank you
for being on hot breath here buddy
absolutely buddy thank you alright have
a good day hey hot brother and sister if
you love comedy as much as we do here at
hot breath click the subscribe button to
join the hot breath averse and then
watch more videos to get even more
comedy tips